salut bienvenue dans cette vidéo un peu
un petit peu spécial non en vrai les
spéciales parce qu'on va jouer au jeu
que j'ai co créé avec céline âge qui
s'appelle menteur menteur c'est un jeu
de mensonges entre amis j'ai invité
plein de copains et de copines youtuber
qui aiment jouer à jouer avec nous
aujourd'hui vous allez voir ça donc déjà
depuis chez vous vous allez pouvoir
jouer et essayer de trouver les menteurs
à chaque fois et comprendre les règles
du jeu et surtout voir comment tout ça
ça se passe mais cette vidéo ça va être
une vidéo un peu au rythme est un peu
monté
sachez que dans la description de cette
vidéo il ya toute une partie en entier
qu'on va tourner là dans quelques
instants que je mettrais voilà sans
montage si vous voulez voir une partie
entière comment tout ce déroule tous les
cas de figure exc
on se retrouve à la fin de la vidéo je
vous en dis un petit peu plus avec des
choses importantes
donc n'hésitez pas à quoi qu'il arrive à
aller voir la fin d'une manière ou d'une
autre et bien une bonne vidéo à tous
merci
on est donc un petit peu plateaux télé
gaming est en mode l'aula du be me
céline h match bird
conax est bonne aujourd'hui nous allons
jouer à un jeu que j'ai co créé avec
céline h qui s'appelle menteur menteur
[Musique]
est apparu aux opinions pour cinq termes
entend acheter un max bert vient
derrière magnifique ça lady prochaine
commande avec le code bird
donc ça c'est un jeu entre amis basé sur
le mensonge on peut jouer de trois
joueurs à 37 villes joueurs ce même plus
de joueurs par contre c'est un jeu
individuel et non pas collectif donc pas
l'équipe au malgré la chambre des deux
pupitres comme ça comme souvent avec le
mensonge
d'ailleurs on est tout seul avec simon
c'est ça et tu va ponctuer cette phrase
de philosophie il n'y a pas de ya pas de
slogan pour ce jeu je vous demande à
tous de près par un slogan que nous
allons découvrir ou redécouvrir
je vais commencer par le merveilleux doc
seven menteur menteur le jeu que tu vas
kiffer jeu avec tonton temps imparti
culture web et pourquoi pas être bien
l'individu montherlant terre joué avec
le coeur et oui c'est vrai dire c'est
l'amour c'est l'amour
moi je suis forcément parce que
l'alternateur joue avec le coeur et
abonne toi avec le boucher ont dit la
vérité
baird bontin menteur pas le film avec
jim carrey et le jeu de fabien olicard
et céline ce qu'ils fabriquent un
menteur menteur ht an afin que je puisse
partir on seychelles tous les ans la
passion de l'argent
petit récap eu des règles les amis oui
oui vous allez tout savoir une carte
joueurs une carte accusations afin de
d'accuser les autres joueurs encore
offert mesure de la partie
attirer quelques couleurs doc le saumon
s'il te plaît souvent jusqu'au bout
quitte à carthage en accusation mcss gov
je prends le vert le vert accusations
joueurs bien sûr de la dui dit
le terril bleus accusations je te
prendrai à violer mais je te remercie
mais c'est un jeu plein de tous partout
à chaque fois qu'un jour il va
exactement la même mécanique l'a par
exemple il ya quatre joueurs donc je
vais mettre une carte menteur parmi
trois cartes vérité et vous allez
piocher une de ces cartes l'un d'entre
vous l'une d'entre vous dira la vérité
et mensonge et les autres diront la
vérité
attention à dieuze règle de trois
attention les règles oui où
[Musique]
te tire une carte confidences de ce pas
parle-nous du pire cadeau que dante et
fait donc dans quelques secondes
rafraîchissez à cette réponse en
fonction de si vous dites la vérité au
mensonge
mais la question sera par le nom du
quart cadeau que l'on ait fait ou quel
est le cadeau que l'on tfc aubry parce
qu'il ya forcément des gens qui la wii
si vous regardez la vidéo la même façon
ses portes à l'asie
williams dans le dos du pire cadeau que
l'on ait fait c'était une chemise à
fleurs quand j'étais en terminale
pendant les mercer mais super ok super
si on veut en savoir plus on te pose des
questions la chemise à fleurs en
terminale
un couple de perroquets coupe des
périodes assez beau j'accuserai
maquisards déjà conséquent savoir depuis
2006 un porte-clés patte de lapin le
lahbiri moi c'est un livre sur la fin un
des tomes sur les sculptures de
l'antiquité jusqu'à nos jours
[Musique]
ban de la confidence j'en appelle au
jingle de la face persuasion ding on a
complètement délégués les jingles et non
c'est moi qui aie
nous allons passer la phase de
persuasion on regarde le même ordre
durant une minute tu peux interrogées
qui tu veux mais qu'une seule personne
dès que je dirais top tu dois te lancer
si t'as pas encore décidé la décidera de
phase i will gamme
c'est parti maintenant tu en as fait
quoi d'être perroquet c'est sur moi bah
y'en a un qui est mort et l'autre que
j'ai réagi
il est mort comme en bas il est mort il
s'est laissé fondre les muscles tondre
fallait en fait c'était en cache des
petits perroquets s'appelle ghetto et
dévoila et du cou
diana il s'est un peu laissé crever
comme je me disais que je me doutais que
le deuxième allait se laisser crever à
son tour j'étais le relâche les kits
offert sa un ami il faut cesser de
penser j'étais fan des oiseaux ils
savaient pas que c'était les oiseaux
observés dans la nature et que ça me
dérange des animaux j'ai envie de vous
dire une chose c'est que le temps est
écoulé non mais attendez de voir tu as
une minute pour interroger qui tue le
monde quand même si tu veux et ça va
être partie dans trois jeux v1 1 g par
céline ok quitte à faire cette patte de
lapin jetant un coup pas en fait non je
t'explique en fait c'était à un
anniversaire et c'était genre et les
petits cadeaux de merde on n'avait pas
beaucoup d'argent quoi et donc tout le
monde avait quand même terme petit
effort des petites bêtises quoi un petit
bloc un petit shampoing il me l ai
trouvé ça drôle de me ramener pour toi
on ne l'a pas en mode c'est de la chance
mais en fait je fais c'est dégueulasse
j'ai pas osé lui dire tout de suite mais
j'ai déjà pu la garder
j'avais 19 ans et avec combien de
personnes atteintes anniversaire ah oui
à des cinq personnes n'avaient pas
beaucoup avec l'âge j'avais 19 ans et
vous avez j'étais encore sur pc 1000h
que sa commande d'a321 maintenant ok
pourquoi ne sait si terrible cette
chemise qu'elle avait bien parce qu'ils
m'ont fait croire qu'elle était super
stylé donc j'ai mis tout le temps alors
qu'en fait tout le monde se foutait le
médiator
c'était en australie quand j'ai fait ma
terminale d'accord donc en fait le côté
truc à fleurs et tout ça va c'est pas
gênant comme moi mais c'était très laid
quand tu regardes les photos maintenant
c'est parce qu'à ce moment là tu te
rendais compte que c'est non pas du tout
on n'en sait là avec le recul non moi
j'avais là en réalité c'est pas ton pire
cadeau
je peux vraiment cadeau règle sinon à
part ça c'est terminé
mais après le la des lycées par coup
dans 3 2 1
parce que je voulais savoir exactement
qu'est ce que tu en as fait de cette pas
tellement ah ben je les gardais dans un
tiroir et après je crois que j'ai pas
tardé d'accord alors là vous dites
comment promenant sur techno se situe
jamais jamais je n'ai jamais mis cette
pâte de la non mais c'est une patte de
lapin c'est moi je feins ces piscines
spas de la pensée de safetic
maintenant chacun va s'équiper de sa fin
de sa carte accusations ah oui et
d'aller tous nous rapprocher du centre
vous allez présenter votre carte comme
ceux ci un petit peu comme si vous
faisiez impact et je vais compter
jusqu'à 3 un jeu à trois vous posez
votre carte sur le crâne de la personne
que vous voulez accusé sa direction en
simultané sans même temps attention
accusations 3 2 1 mais maintenant
j'aimerais que le ou la menteuse décline
son identité
la menteuse elle accusé qu'une fois que
tu a accusé le seul fois un film le la
du midi marque 3 points
et en plus elle pioche une carte vrai
faux comme le joueur menteur n'a été
réalisée que par une personne c'est un
genre drame marque quand même un point
merci beaucoup mais c'est être
convaincant hockey
dans une deuxième partie on a avec noomi
code céline sache doc seven mike byrd et
fabien olicard tu n'as pas joué au jeu
du slogan il faut que tu présentes un
slogan pour monter un menteur menteur
menteur les meilleurs jeux en tracteur a
entre action compris entre acteurs non
j'ai encore la vérité parlement la
confidence et non pas confiture
ah bon faut maintenant je m'attacherai à
moteur telle est la pire vacheries que
tu es fait un ami et là tu as envie
d'avoir la carte et bien moi j'avais
deux amis qui étaient en couple et j'ai
su qu'un jour une part la fille avait un
peu fricoter avec un autre mec
et je fallait pas que je dise je voulais
pas le dire et puis gelé un moment je
les dis bah cadeau de noël de ma mère
que j'ai revendu sans qu'elle le sache
sans que personne le rêve jusqu'à
présent c'est une exclusivité
moi je
j'étais en vélo j'ai vu le chien de mon
pote à l'agonie sur le bas côté et j'ai
continué moi c'est pour à propos de
photos d'oiseaux en fait je savais où il
y avait le nid d'un pic et j'ai pas
vraiment eu le dit un petit peu à tes
copains qui font de la faute aussi
et pour pas qu'ils fassent les mêmes
photos et ben je les ai pas dit et j'ai
montré les photos après et plus et plus
qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé à ce chien
ben je sais pas je m'aligne s'est fait
shooter par une voiture et tu savais tu
l'as tu a reconnu le château entouré de
collines et moi je suis pas sûr encore
maintenant facile parce qu'après une
lundi c est pourquoi tu la laisser comme
ça parce que certains ventre mais c'est
horrible c'est assez horrible mais si
monde
bah oui dieu j'étais en retard encore
une âme du coup quand on m'a dit [ __ ]
leur nom âge et mon chien reçoit demain
à toulouse
[ __ ] ils étaient où sony sony n'était
sur une petite route que près de près de
la côte à la route de guatemala hockey
et y aller comment j allais à vélo est
alors faite le
[Musique]
le truc il était plutôt accessible sur
le bord de la route en bagnole il ya
plein de gens qui me font cette route
s'il avait dit où était le ni
franchement a été facile c'était pas de
cadeaux vélo a revendu en vélo et
personne ne s'en est rendu compte
bah si mais plus tard pendu il est amer
est a demandé il est où l'on veut mais
si j'aimais suivent eddy genre genre
maintenant les gens sont au courant mais
c'était un fait c'est un vélo c'était un
vélo jaune qui était beaucoup trop petit
et qu'on les avait achetés sur leboncoin
ou alors il sait qui est le menteur est
en fait qui vous emmène sur l'île pour
être le seul à la crise alimentaire
jal était ami avec un couple voilà et
jeter autant ami avec un que l'autre et
tu savais qu'il fallait pas dire que
l'une avec 38 oui souvent le samedi en
sortant de boîte mais même si tu as vécu
tout on est déjà à domicile 8 et
pluvieux puis se taper des filles tu
vois mais je disais rien c'est mon pote
tu vois et elle l était pas une fois
mais bien moins que lui ouais et moi
foire je les vieux mec chez plus on
discute et j'avais un petit peu bu et
j'étais pas complètement je laissé sous
entendre qu il a compris et j'ai eu oui
alors forcément quand il sait jamais à
temps elle sous-entend tout et c'est
physique
la question mais la pression j'ai dit
elle avait fricoté avec un orgueil
j'adorerais la carte est relation vient
se placer ici 1 2 3 mais non la leader
il est doué au lit car je mens tu es
belle je mentais couvert le pas ce qu'il
faut savoir
il faut savoir qu'en guyane sur les
photos d'oiseaux tu peux pas faire ça tu
peux pas faire ça tout le monde sait
scruter se situe valence si tu balances
sur internet des photos en disant que
c'est des données scientifiques c'est à
dire que tu comptabilise quand est ce
que tu as vu le jour
[Musique]
j'espère que ce que vous avez vous ça
vous a plu je vous donne des petites
informations par contre qu'ils sont
essentiels je vous le répète dans la
description de la vidéo vous avez une
partie en entier qui est quasiment pas
monter et comme ça vous pouvez voir tous
les cas de figure et puis voir la partie
en entière elle est plutôt drôle
merci à william donc d'opter jeunes à
max bird amis code à l'aula du mini à
céline âge vous mais leurs cinq chaînes
dans la description n'hésitez pas allez
checker joue mais également les deux
livres de max bird et de doc seven qui
sont assez cool dans la description et
dans la description également vous allez
retrouver un lien vers la boutique la
mienne vous pouvez trouver le jeu vous
pouvez aussi d'ailleurs trouvé le livre
de doc et de william également ce
t-shirt tee shirt un petit peu spécial
parce que il peut mentaliser les gens
dire qu'avec le tee shirt et fourni une
vidéo t'explique comment faire du
mentalisme avec le petit chat je crois
que je vous ai tout dit voilà encore
merci à tous les copains et copines qui
sont venus faire le truc vraiment si
vous connaissez pas leur chaîne allait
checker allez voir c'est très très cool
merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo
n'oubliez pas de cliquer n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner n'oubliez pas que je
vous kiffe ciao
[Musique]
m